Welcome back everyone this is going to be my loki
episode 6 finale video and holy crap there's so
much to talk about so many easter eggs and they
set so much of what's happening during marvel
phase 4 up it blew my mind so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's going to
be a lot to talk about for a long time after this
i'm also still doing the weekly giveaway for
disney plus memberships details about that down in
the description careful for spoilers if you have
not seen the episode yet and there are some big
spoilers that we have to talk about starting with
the title of the episode for all time always which
is the motto of the time variance authority the
tba but you could also call this episode the one
with all the explainers based on everything that
was going on with this version of kang or immortus
however you want to think about him he was more
like a mortise than he was like kang because
he's like the oldest final boss formed version of
himself but knowing everything we know about him
getting all those reveals the actual phrase for
all time always is now a reference to the mission
the quest that he was on that he was trying to
get loki and silvie to take over for him he had
to watch over the timeline prevent all these other
branches to keep other versions of himself at bay
for all time always then the episode starts
with a brand new intro scene of the marvel
studios logo so they change it this time and they
start with captain america and peggy carter's song
that they were dancing to at the end of avengers
end game it's also the same song from the first
captain america movie too that's why they kind of
brought it back around for end game but then they
cut a montage of scenes of overlapping dialogue
and moments from all the marvel movies so far
it starts with falcon during captain america
civil war saying way to go tic tac then it's
black widow from iron man 2 showing happy how to
punch then black panther screaming wakanda forever
during avengers infinity war ant-man meeting
falcon for the first time black widow during
the first avengers movie when colson calls
her like let me put you on hold for a second
peter quill's dance off from the end of the
first guardians of the galaxy movie then thor
from ragnarok fighting hulk saying he's a friend
from work captain america fighting himself during
avengers end game with that funny i can do this
all day moment yeah yeah i know hank pym from the
flashbacks to shield in the first ant-man movie
captain marvel from before she got her powers
with maria rambo the higher further faster loki's
saying we have a hulk to thanos during avengers
infinity war then korg escaping with the other
asgardians during ragnarok then they just pile
on hundreds and hundreds of scenes on top of each
other so you can't tell who's talking but you can
kind of pick out some of them like there's some
iron man dialogue it's basically representing big
seminal scenes from all the avengers movies
and all the different avengers characters
then the next montage they show you is sort of
like the life cycle of a universe in the timeline
starting in being reborn it's meant to foreshadow
the big kang reveal and the way that he paved the
road so to speak paved the sacred timeline so
during this part of the montage they start using
moments from real world history dialogue from
neil armstrong nelson mandela even greta thurnberg
but as the camera spins out sort of zooming out
moving forward in time there's a spaceship here
that looks very advanced that could be an easter
egg for the spaceship that renslayer was talking
about the prototype ship but this spaceship here
could also just be a random spaceship from the
future just to show you how technology progresses
naturally but that's basically what's happening
here you're getting the speed run version of a
timeline and what we witness here when this planet
sort of collapses is we're witnessing a big bang
cycle for this particular sun like this universe
expands future unfolds then eventually the sun
we're looking at dies collapses into a black hole
then eventually another contraction and another
big bang happens another version of the infinity
stones would be created then as well but then a
new version of this particular universe is born in
the timeline for it starts again starts again at
zero basically then as the camera zooms out again
you see other universes going through the
same cycle representing alternate timelines
then we get that voiceover from classic loki dying
saying glorious purpose and when they go full 2001
space odyssey like when all the colors start to
bleed together as you're moving forward in the
timeline faster and faster we're witnessing kang
basically building the sacred timeline so to speak
the way he talks about he isolated our timeline
and then sort of weaved together what became the
sacred timeline they include visions dialogue
from one division when he said what is grief
if not love persevering you can see the synergy
here as they're referencing a lot of other disney
plus series during these opening scenes there's
a little bit of dialogue from sylvie earlier on
the series talking to r loki and it's all meant to
foreshadow the road that kang paved when he says
to them i pave this road you're just walking down
because then it shifts to a larger macro view of
the sacred timeline and it actually does kind of
look like a road like the bifrost existing through
space space-time then we stop on the asteroid at
the end of time with loki and sylvie walking up
to the door basically in the moments right after
the end of last week's episode which now we know
is the show's version of chronopolis there were a
lot of people that were wondering what was going
on with kang there were so many kang easter eggs
that i was talking about during my episode 5 video
but i was so surprised how hard they rolled on
kang marvel did not need to roll this hard given
what they did on one division in holding back on
doctor strange it's almost like the loki writers
and producers saw what they did with juan division
and how it was sort of tied and setting up doctor
strange 2 multiverse of madness in what falcon
and winter soldier did to sort of set up what's
going on in the future of the mcu and said hold
my beer we can do one better we're going to take
that major villain from the upcoming marvel
movie ant-man 3 quantomania and we're going
to introduce him on our show we don't know who the
villain of doctor strange 2 is going to be there's
been a lot of rumors about the schumacher being
the main villain but that would have been like
one division introducing schumachorth in their
post-credit scene this is how big a deal it is
for them to introduce kang for the first time
in the mcu on a marvel disney plus series the
doors open on their own not only because it's
really advanced technology and kang controls
everything but also because he wants things to
play out this way because he knows how it's going
to play out at least up to a certain point miss
minutes greets them confirming that she is also
every bit as evil as everybody thought she
was most of us knew that she would somehow
be connected to whoever was behind all this but
she's kind of like an ai so someone would have
had to create her and whoever created her would
have been the man behind the curtain which we now
find out is kang the conqueror or a version of
kang the way he talks about himself names what
do they matter i've had many names i'll talk
about that too because he does make a lot of
references to the many different versions of
himself from the comics who it sounds like
we're actually going to be seeing in the upcoming
marvel movies but when miss minutes greets them
she refers to the person in charge as he who
remains who is actually a different comic book
character who i've talked about in previous
videos i think we all collectively knew that
whoever the big reveal was going to be it
would be a version of mcu he who remains
so in the comics he who remains is different from
all the versions of kang and the mcu just sort of
combining those characters but during this episode
in the subtitles and in the credits at the end
they only refer to him as he who remains so what
they'll probably do is they'll wait till ant-man
3 or doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness
because a lot of what happened here in the ending
sets up doctor strange 2 they'll wait to those
movies to actually call him kang by name i think
the version that we meet during this episode is
actually closer to being a version of immortus
because he's at the end of his timeline in what
he's been doing this whole time controlling the
tva using his version of chronopolis to control
everything all of time is what immortus did after
the tva started working with him in the comics
but now because we know exactly what's going on
with it this whole time kang was responsible for
everything it would also be accurate to say that
this place has been chronopolis this whole time
but just to distinguish different versions of
his character so we keep referring to him as kang
because kevin feige said that the main villain of
ant-man 3 would be kang the conqueror but in the
comics kang was actually much more of a lesser
mid-boss level time travel villain for the
avengers still very very powerful but immortus
was supposed to be the final boss forum version
of kang later in his time like millions of years
in the future and this version of king says that
he's been alive for millions of years so that's
why he was being kind of ambiguous about what his
name actually was when he says i've had many names
but because of what they do at the end of the
episode with him teasing this big kang war across
the multiverse multiversal war 2.0 it sounds like
they'll use those alternate versions to show us
the many different versions of kang like rama tut
scarlett centurion immortus there are many to go
around but through miss minutes kang offers them a
deal to put them back into the timeline where they
came from they can go back to the way things were
but also like new game plus mode if we're talking
about the video game model here them reliving
their lives but with a bunch of extra junk on top
she says that loki could win the battle of
new york defeat the avengers he could also
have the infinity gauntlet he could kill
thanos he could have the throne of asgard
anything he wants but also sylvie could wake up
happy having always been happy her whole life
they can live together have the relationship
that they want and kane could make it so that
no one around them would think that it's weird
you have to imagine thorl would raise a pretty
big red flag but that gives you an idea for how
powerful kang is that he can manipulate time
that way he can make things any way you want he
can weave together any aspects of any timelines
and make it so that it all holds together they
both turn her down flat but here's the funny thing
kang actually knows everything that's going to
happen here up to a certain point later in the
episode so he knew that they were going to deny
this but it's all part of him testing them to make
sure that they're the right ones to take his place
or could take his place because like he says he
didn't know what choice they were eventually going
to make so here's the funny analogy i'll make it's
kind of like willy wonka in the chocolate factory
kang is willy wonka orchestrating this grand
contest to see who is worthy to take his place to
take over the factory it's just that he makes time
he doesn't make chocolate and the funny thing too
jonathan majors is a fantastic actor so i can't
wait to see what he does with the future of this
character but the way he performs his version of
kang is way more flamboyant way more theatrical
than i ever would have thought how i'm able to
get out of the way just before you kill me like we
make jokes about how loki is so theatrical like he
flips his hair back every time he falls down and
he did it again during this episode like that's a
requirement of the character he has to fall down
on his face then flip his hair up really pissed
off jonathan major's version of kang here is so
theatrical and over the top that he makes loki
seem tame by comparison but then we jump back
to the tva check in with ravona renslayer who's
downloading the files that she needs that'll get
her to the citadel at the end of time she seems a
little regretful when she sees mobius's rings from
his drinks on the table but before she can think
too much about it miss minute shows up giving
her a completely different set of files based
on kang's instructions that he claims will be way
more helpful to her so even though it seems like
the episode got a little timey-wimey like which
version of kang is she going to meet at what point
in his timeline the idea is that sylvie might have
killed him at the end of the episode but that's
just him at the end of his timeline the version
that ravona probably went to see was much earlier
in his timeline but then we jump back to loki and
sylvie walking through the halls of the citadel
and as the camera rotates around it's mostly just
to be extra trippy to really disorient you because
they're really disoriented here's the really
interesting detail though you actually see four
time keeper statues but one of them has been
smashed implying that this fourth one was king
the conqueror they don't really explain why it was
smashed only i think the idea that other people
have come to his citadel here and he sort of tried
to measure them to see if they were worthy like
he's had previous willy wonka contests to see if
other versions of loki have been worthy to take
over and maybe they had some sort of fight here
and that's what damaged the statue but then speak
of the devil and he shall appear the door opens
to the elevator revealing jonathan majors as kang
for the first time in the mcu and he's basically
wearing a version of his comic book costume like
you can see the purple robes but like i said he's
a little bit closer to a mortise and it's not
until later in the episode when he does his little
backstory explainer using his special temp pad and
then even later inside the new version the tva
with the big statue of kang that you really see a
true comic book accurate kang costume immortus was
more known for wearing flowing robes like jonathan
major's character is wearing here absolutely loved
his performance the way he plays it so casual
is just a little unsettling because you know how
powerful he is they have the scene where sylvie
tries to kill him just so he can reveal that he
has a more advanced version of the same technology
that the tva hunters used to manipulate time for
himself in the way he explains it later in the
episode is that he actually has it pre-programmed
so that it automatically moves him around in time
and space so that people can't kill him he doesn't
have to punch in commands like the other tva
hunters do like he doesn't have to put his finger
on it to get it to work it just automatically does
all these things because he's pre-programmed
it that's why he's so utterly unconcerned about
sylvie trying to kill him because it's all part
of his plan that we jump back to the tva mobius
has his big surprise scene with renslayer and
they sort of have it out for a little while
trying to argue over the morality of what's going
on and they finally reveal what was going on with
that blue pen from earlier on the show that seemed
like they were setting up some big twist hunter
b15 purposefully travels back to this high school
so that the other tva hunters will chase her there
and see what it is that she's trying to reveal
that this is where ren slater came from at some
point here she did something that caused the
nexus event became a variant and then that's
when her time at the tva started in the variant
version that we're seeing here in the tva just
kept the pen as a memento of her life before this
so it's all about revealing the truth of the tba
that they're all variants to the other hunters
as well but then when we go back to kang he says
he knows about sylvie's long journey to get here
he calls loki a flea on the back of a dragon you
barely held on but you did it this mostly just
meant to be a metaphor for the epic events that
he's been through up to this point like all the
events of the marvel movies the infinity saga
story line with thanos and then everything that's
happened through the course of the loki show
you could also think of the reference to a dragon
being a callback to silvie's dragon when she was
playing with it as a child and then also to the
mid guard serpent which is loki's child in norse
mythology i also love the way he shows them
their pages of dialogue when they keep trying
to kill him like okay let's just get past this
i'm going to show you why it is that you're not
going to be able to touch me unless i want you
to touch me and it's basically the exact same
pages like you saw when loki had to sign them
when he first got arrested by the tva the same
pages that everyone has to sign when they get
arrested by them the difference is is that kang
is just even further forward in the timeline so
he has pages that go beyond when loki was arrested
a lot of you also been asking in the end credits
there's this mystery hand on top of all the files
and usually with each new episode the files will
change there'll be pictures depicting the events
of what happened during the previous episode so
i think they're trying to say here that this is
kang's hand and he's been watching them this whole
time because that's basically what he tells loki
and sylvie like you've been doing everything the
way i wanted you to do it that's what he meant
when he said that he saw the wonderful moment that
they shared on lamentus 1 in front of the lake
he was literally watching that unfold when he
talks about the journey changing them along the
way and how that was necessary that all just
plays into the idea of his willy wonka like
contest his test to them to see if they
were the right ones to take over for him
he wanted them to gain this broader perspective so
that they could make that moral choice that loki
actually kind of starts to make before sylvie
eventually winds up punting him back to the tva
and when he talks about them finishing the quest
together with him like saying that he's part of
this his grand plan is all about maintaining the
integrity of the timeline the safety of this one
timeline by keeping the other versions of him at
bay that is his life's quest but then back with
mobius and renslayer she doubles down on how she
believes it's necessary for kang who she doesn't
know about quite yet she only knows that there's a
person in control giving her orders and is telling
her to come meet them that it's somehow a good
thing that only he be allowed to have true free
will because otherwise the multiverse would erupt
into chaos there is definitely chaos at the end of
the episode probably just not what she's expecting
or in the form that she's expecting she also
reveals during this fight that they have here that
she and mobius had known each other for at least a
couple thousand years when she says a couple eons
of friendship she stops mobius then heads through
the portal and we don't really see her again
till we'll pick up with her during season two
now she might wind up crossing over into future
marvel movie we'll see is part of kang's storyline
but like i said it sounds like the version that
she's going to meet is at some point earlier in
his timeline the production design is amazing but
there are easter eggs all over the background here
all over the place you kind of have to wait
for the camera to rotate around in different
shots to see them all but they also use some of
the cinematography in the way they frame kang
to help tell his story the way they frame him in
front of these windows almost makes it look like
a giant face consuming all of them as he starts
talking about how powerful he is in all the things
that he's done to create the tva and protect the
timeline it just winds up making him feel way more
powerful but he's not wrong when he says that he
created the tva to prevent another multiverse war
if i don't do this everything in existence burns
referencing the chaos that another kang war would
bring across the multiverse then when he starts
referencing the other versions of himself that
he's afraid of like oh i'm afraid of me he starts
referencing his other comic book names like rama
tut the conquer obviously a reference to kang
the conquer i've already explained some of the
changes they made to he who remains combining his
character with kangs but those are just only some
of them like i said we'll probably see the other
versions of kang in these future marvel movies
but then he actually narrates the true history of
the mcu like the true history of the timeline in
the history of the tva when he references the
scientists from the 31st century that person
is nathaniel richards from the comics who was
a distant descendant of reed richard's father
who was also named nathaniel richards so kang is
kind of related to mr fantastic of the fantastic
four and we know we're getting a new fantastic
four movie even though i feel like this is more
connected to doctor strange 2 and ant-man 3 but
the mcu version of this backstory this explainer
on the loki series is that mcu nathaniel richards
discovered the secrets of the multiverse alternate
timelines in a way that people like iron man hank
pym had not done before to a degree that they had
not done before eventually the same thing happened
with other alternate universe versions of him from
alternate timelines they started working together
which i think is meant to be a big reference to
the council of reeds from the comics another
big fantastic four connection like a council
of kangs from the multiverse but then he says
eventually some of the other variants of himself
started going rogue trying to conquer quote other
universes going full king the conqueror in that
wound up ending the peace between all versions of
himself like the council that they had broke up
and it erupted into the multiverse war that miss
minutes was referencing in the tva propaganda
video during episode 1 that was the original
multiverse war with each kang variant fighting
to preserve their universe you also notice when
they're fighting here they're using those same
looking wands that you see renslayer using in
the other tv8 hunters he also explains that
they shared a lot of technology across different
universes so a lot of the technology that he's
using now the tva technology is an amalgam of a
bunch of different alternate realities but then
he says the first version of nathaniel richards
the original is the one who found goliath who was
capable of consuming space-time consuming whole
realities he was created from all the tares and
reality caused by the first kang multiverse
war then says that he experimented on goliath
weaponized him and he was able to use him to end
that first multiverse war which implies that he
the person we're staring at here is that original
nathaniel richards just later in his timeline
then he isolated his own timeline created the tva
to prevent further branches from being created or
at least dangerous branches that would result in
dangerous versions of himself from coming into
existence and that's what we're staring at here
the sacred timeline i do like the way that he
hypes up this kang multiverse war though if you
think that i'm bad if you think that i'm evil
wait till you meet some of the other versions of
me kang says that he's lived through a million
lifetimes searching for the person or the
people that are right to take over for him
and he's finally found them and it just happened
to be two people loki and sylvie but he's actually
not kidding here he's literally lived through a
million lifetimes and he's millions of years old
when we see him here and he remembers everything
from all these other timelines so the way he
manipulates time is what gives him functional
immortality that's why his final boss form in
the comics is called immortus is a reference to
him being functionally immortal so when he says
that he's old that's a dramatic understatement
and the reason why he kind of wants to give it
up why he wants someone to take over willy wonka
style i'm tired i would like to retire he's been
at it for millions of years so of course anybody
would get tired of this and because of his complex
understanding of how the timeline works he doesn't
really care whether or not they either take over
for him or they kill him because he knows that if
they kill him they'll just wind up right back here
in another version of the timeline that's sort
of what they were setting up with the big cycle
of big bangs at the beginning of the episode with
that intro scene so even though some things might
be different in this new timeline because she
does wind up killing him most of the really big
stuff will all go down in similar ways that's kind
of what he was talking about with reincarnation
but that also gets into some really metaphysical
spiritual stuff that they'll probably talk about
a little bit more during doctor strange 2 and
when he comes back during ant-man 3. so i did
love the loki versus sylvie fight but the whole
idea here is that he doesn't want to hurt her
so he's holding back but she's not which is
why he gets kicked around a whole bunch more
when he gets knocked into the bookshelves
you actually start to see some of kang's
artifacts that he's collected over the countless
centuries millions of years that he's been alive
like a lot of these artifacts look like they're
from all across earth's history going back to
ancient history also probably stuff from alternate
alien planets as well just meant to be comic book
easter eggs for the versions of kang that travel
to ancient history ballsy move 2 he teleports
himself into the path of her blade banking on the
hope that she'll stop swing and not chop his head
off he winds up talking you're down but when he
says he understands how she feels he's been there
he's talking about old school loki from the events
of the first thor movie when he learned about
odin's deception and what that drove him to do
during that movie and then he winds up finishing
his confession of sorts that he was making when
ravona rensselaer pruned him back in episode four
she reciprocates his feelings and they have their
big kiss i know everyone was wondering if they
were actually going to kiss on the show i don't
know if it's twincest call it what you want it's
like they've taken a notch up from game of thrones
but then because she cares about him but she
doesn't want to stop she punts him back to the tva
saving him from this place like sending him back
to where he'll be safe and then when she kills
kang what he means when he says i'll see you soon
is that time will just unfold exactly the same and
they'll wind up in the same place again eventually
then you see the timeline fracturing into infinite
branches infinite alternate universes and they go
back to the tva and this is very reminiscent from
the end of episode two when they set up all the
time reset devices and it started fracturing
the timeline a little bit only this time it's
sort of like a christmas tree going crazy with
alternate branches then after our loki collects
himself and sort of realizes that they have to
move forward now like what do we do about this
all these dangerous people he has to warn everyone
he goes to find mobius in the archives but then
much to his sugar in mobius and hunter b-15 have
no idea who he is wait a minute who are you are
you an analyst what's going on here and as he
looks up and sees the giant statue of kang in his
full comic book costume comic book accurate and it
seems like it's replaced the time keepers statues
i think what they're implying here is that sylvie
whether on purpose or on accident pushed him into
an alternate reality where history played out
differently and this version of kang who the
statue is depicting just created the tva without
using the false dogma about the time keepers like
he was always honest about who he was when he was
ordering these people around so at least right
now it just seems like he's been thrown into an
alternate timeline there's a new version of the
credits here at the end with kang's picture and
the events of what happened in his tower there
you also see a hand down in the corner here i
believe based on what kang was talking about
watching all this unfold this whole time the hand
is meant to be kang's hand then at the end there's
a sort of post-credit scene mid-credit scene they
stamp loki's file revealing that the show has been
renewed for season two although they haven't
revealed the release date like i said i think
that'll be between the events of doctor strange
2 and ant-man 3 because thr is now reporting that
loki is supposed to show up in doctor strange
2 multiverse of madness with scarlet witch and
doctor strange i'll do a couple bonus videos in
the next couple of days talking about how this
is going to affect everything in the movies that
are coming up like doctor strange 2 spider-man no
way home ant-man 3 quantum mania but there was so
much stuff that they revealed during this so many
easter eggs it'll probably take a couple more
re-watches to spot everything if there are any
big easter eggs that you feel like you spotted in
the episode that i didn't talk about in the video
just write them below in the comments the next big
marvel disney plus series is going to be marvel's
what if my episode videos for that will start in
a couple of weeks so make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss anything
and for those of you that have been asking me to
do more on camera stuff i will probably do more
on camera stuff for the what if episode videos at
least for the bigger episode videos but while you
wait for everything everyone click here for all
my loki episode videos and bonus videos and click
here for that brand new video of deadpool crossing
over into the mcu thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!